hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 13th 2020 Christ I gotta
make sure I'm quiet man I'm in this
[ __ ] hotel room and their walls are
thin all right and there's been some
[ __ ] Cougars it nextdoor
been [ __ ] I don't know what they've
been doing but they've been up all
[ __ ] nights and I feel like they're
sleeping late or some [ __ ] so I got it I
got to have my inside voice here I'm
still in New Orleans
it is Sunday night when I'm doing this
it's right before halftime and the
Packers are beating my Super Bowl
prediction sneaky pete in the seattle
seahawks 20 to 3 and i am going to the
[ __ ] national championship game
tonight and i just found out that
president Trump is also going which
means this is going to be a [ __ ]
trying to get into the venue so I figure
if we get there about 19 hours early
after all the pat downs and all of that
[ __ ] you know if I was president I
wouldn't go to games I'm like this is
gonna lose me votes bread and circus
just let the [ __ ] common people go
down there get hammered you know do a
little bit of line dance and eat a
couple of [ __ ] pralines a guy now
they got to go down to the [ __ ] game
let me ask you a question
all right then this isn't like partisan
politics and what the [ __ ] is a
president going to a goddamn game for
don't you have like a next-level
flat-screen TV that you can literally
stick your head into and look around the
[ __ ] arena you're the president you
know I never knew him to be a football
fan but at least he's going and that
that other guy the other guy that pinch
guy he's not going that guy's a bummer
man if he [ __ ] showed up something
would happen you know some chick would
show her tits and he'd get all [ __ ]
upset and then he would be a do a big
grandiose walkout you know acting like a
white chick you know this isn't perfect
for me so I'm leaving and I know and I
get up to leave everybody's gonna care
so anyway I don't even know where to
[ __ ] start I've been in New Orleans
for like the last three days before I
talk about the absolute craziness of
that [ __ ] in Kansas City game I can't
even remember who the that game was so
[ __ ] nuts I can't remember who the
[ __ ] play the day before San Francisco
beat the Vikings and somebody else beats
somebody though the Titans won again
remember the Titans
no wait the Titans be Buffalo last week
no the Titans beat the [ __ ] Ravens
Jesus Christ alright let's let's get to
the [ __ ] first which is just my
stupid shows I won't thank everybody
that came out to the Mahalia Jackson why
am i saying come on Wilson the guys
running for his [ __ ] life picking on
the wrong guy here Oh Billy ball watcher
here anyway Mahalia Jackson theater
played three nights they're just an
amazing amazing crowds each crowd was
better than the next I had such a good
time it was all like New Orleans locals
for the most part and they were day was
so much fun man and I got the new wow
man the new hour yeah you know it
[ __ ] all came together right it's
like when those people get ready you
know the actors and models and [ __ ] when
they get ready for a shoot you know what
I mean they just cut out water and salt
and all of that [ __ ] just it's it's
tightening up all right you start I'm
starting to see the cheekbones of the
other yakked here I'm really like in the
direction that it's going in and at
least it's working in the middle of the
country we'll see how it works on the
sensitive coasts those [ __ ] [ __ ]
New York and LA why do they tell the
whole [ __ ] country what they should
and shouldn't be [ __ ] doing I don't
know what happened they you know two of
the coolest cities with some of the
greatest people but there's like [ __ ]
eight people in each city who seem to be
telling every
what they should or shouldn't be doing
so whatever it's been working out here
so very excited about that bartnik oh my
god bartnik was [ __ ] murdering he was
like Martin this is killing and then
it's just like the crowd is into you and
they've been loving Joe bartnik down
south here in Memphis and in New Orleans
so anyway we just been hanging here in
New Orleans waiting for the big game and
it's so amazing if you ever come down
here this shitshow that is Bourbon
Street I mean I know it's a big party
and all that type of stuff
but like if you just go one block over
you go down with it
royal street Royale Street it's just a
bunch of old people antiquing there's
occasional drunk on his way to Bourbon
Street but you get on Bourbon Street and
all of a sudden you like god damn man I
could get like some a cat puke on me at
any second let's stick the wallet in the
front pocket the whole thing and then
you get on the other side whatever that
next Street is is fine you know if you
drop your laundry off way down the
street on Bourbon Street it's just local
people just [ __ ] but like you can't
go hard like that
so I also found a beignet place which is
like these doughnut powdered donut types
of things that they have down here
everybody goes to this one place Cafe Du
Mall you go there it's just you know
it's people who party on Bourbon Street
trying to sober up with the [ __ ]
doughnuts so this is like [ __ ] 200
people in line for a doughnut okay I'm
sure they're delicious but I'm not doing
that so one of the locals told me about
a place around the corner you know we're
all the locals and the cops go I guess
to get their [ __ ] beignets if they
even do that [ __ ] here you know I mean
it's like I lived in Massachusetts for
27 years I think I had clam chowder like
three times I didn't like it okay it
looked like he had already been consumed
and then spit up by a [ __ ] cow if
that's what it looked like I was not
into it at all and I didn't eat lobster
and all that [ __ ] so they probably
don't even eat those here but it's just
it's a right around the corner I'm not
even say the name
because I'm gonna make you talk to a
local because I'm not gonna blow it up
and [ __ ] it up for the regular people
and last night after our third show we
ended up going to another great place
out here that just has locals and live
music and and you can also smoke cigars
it was like the perfect place it was
just like you know way away from the
French Quarter and all that and I want
that my parents are in town and this
[ __ ] band up there was just kind of
playing blues or whatever then this dude
just showed up out of nowhere he had an
accordion and a harmonica and you know
anywhere else he would just start
playing polka music I don't know what
the [ __ ] you could do with the harmonica
but he's from New Orleans so he made it
sound great
they absolutely [ __ ] killed and I had
the night that I wanted to have with my
parents where it was just like real-deal
New Orleans live music you know good
food and drink and all that it was just
[ __ ] great
so that's what I've been up to so once
again thank you to everybody in Memphis
and New Orleans that have come out to my
show I am ready to [ __ ] do some damage
here on my my tour this year and we got
a bunch of new dates coming up all right
I haven't said that let's talk about the
[ __ ] playoffs look at playoffs
dude what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
happened yesterday I don't I watched the
first game I don't even know what the
first game oh I watched the oh I watched
the San Francisco 49ers beat the
Minnesota Vikings when of the Vikings
ever gonna just push through and give
those [ __ ] poor people up there
Minneapolis st. Paul a goddamn Super
Bowl evidently not this year
congratulations to the 49ers they looked
really solid and their celebration game
is just off the chains I mean they
celebrate more than the Kansas City
Chiefs and that's saying something
both of them we're acting like they were
winning the Super Bowl on every [ __ ]
plate that they made it's the funniest
[ __ ] ever
I love that guy Kelsey but I swear to
god the guy he's literally pushing the
tackler off of him so he can go moonwalk
because he [ __ ] caught a pass for
eight yards and
has all these drops and it's like well
you should dance then to keep the
attention on yourself but I don't know
that's just the old man [ __ ] it just
[ __ ] strikes me is holy remember that
great catch Lynn Swann had that
unbelievable [ __ ] catch he had in a
[ __ ] Super Bowl you know he didn't
dance after I don't understand what the
[ __ ] big deal is so anyway they look
solid as hell and I don't know and then
I went down to go do my show and I
assumed like everybody else that the
Baltimore Ravens were just gonna go out
and have a nice easy [ __ ] day against
the Tennessee Titans and I remember I
was going to go on stage and the
security guard was listening to the game
and I was just like hey you got a score
and he just looks at me he goes 14
nothing Titans I go get the [ __ ] out of
here
like Jesus Christ zombies cranking the
music driving by
oh [ __ ] Little Billy Jane kid is not his
son it's not his son unless it's a white
kid then it's Michael Jackson's son yeah
he stayed in that bleach bath way too
long God that got all the way into his
[ __ ] DNA didn't it
anyway over talaga whatever the [ __ ]
they call it that went all the way into
his [ __ ] nutsack there all right we
get it you're Billie Jean's fan can you
get through the [ __ ] intersection can
you guys hear this as loud as I kid
alright so anyways a lot of hugging a
lot of hugging going on at the watching
right now watching Terry Bradshaw if
some big guy just came walking in
looking like he played a humpback in
[ __ ] Bride of Frankenstein I think he
just told Jimmy Johnson he's gonna go to
the Hall of Fame or something I don't
put that out there some just happened
they were all hugging the guy and then
Jimmy Johnson looked emotional his hair
still stayed perfectly in place needed
Emmitt Smith to come in and then there
and [ __ ] mess it up so it's
I cannot [ __ ] believe that yeah at
this point you got to say the Titans are
for real right they went in there they
went in to Baltimore and the whole just
kicked the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him I
watched a 13 minute highlight of the
game where they they kind of gave you
the flow of the game and it was - it was
over before it even started I never
would have thought that in a million
years it seemed like they were somehow
able to contain Jackson I know he had a
couple of picks but it looked like he
still played great so I'm looking at
that [ __ ] and then I haven't just
haven't watched the Kansas City game
where they were down 24 points and God
blessed the head coach of the Texans the
[ __ ] verbal abuse that that guy is
going to take from some of the most
unathletic people ever IME but it you
just got to say those [ __ ] calls he
made the debt they made no I what the
[ __ ] it's 21 to nothing okay the legit
loudest Stadium in the league Arrowhead
Stadium sounds like a [ __ ] funeral
parlor you couldn't hear a [ __ ] thing
in that Stadium it's fourth and one they
got a chip shot for a field goal and he
decides to consider a fourth down I mean
I going for it on fourth down right and
you just felt the whole stadium come
alive like wait a minute it's is is this
guy gonna [ __ ] this game up is this guy
gonna give us hope burns a time out if I
remember correctly and then kicks does
the smart thing and kicks the field but
that's what kills me Tony Romo's going
like I like this call when he was
considering going for it on fourth down
and Tony Romo is is is I think the best
color guy in the booth in 20 years
he's [ __ ] incredible but I just wish
he would have explained I think he
started to buy Stilton understanding
explain why the [ __ ] in the first
quarter
you would risk not making it on fourth
down getting the crowd back into the
game and given the Kansas City Chiefs
hopes hope right so fortunately they
kicked a field goal they go up 24
nothing like I was losing my mind when
they were considering it going please
tell me they're not gonna [ __ ] do
this right not that I give a [ __ ] who
wins the game cuz I really have you know
cheese fans have been waiting so goddamn
long so there's a part of me that really
wants to see them win it so those people
you know oh yeah he's definitely oh yeah
Pro Football Hall of Famer class of 2012
Jimmie Johnson's cookies choking back
tears that's hilarious
it's also even funnier if you hate the
Cowboys knowing that they drove a Hall
of Fame coach Troy Aikman scrying are
gonna stay drove a Hall of Fame coach
out of town who was so [ __ ] great even
Barry Switzer won one with his team the
next year there's nothing funnier than
seeing a [ __ ] guy trying not to cry
look at him Jesus Christ he looks like
he's looking into the Sun anyway so now
they're up 24 to nothing ok those Kansas
City Chiefs fans they're cut into the
stands it looks look like they just made
barbecue illegal in their City ok
people's bottom lips are quivering all
these people wearing all of their gear
are like oh my god the Patriots are out
of it the Ravens are out of it we have
this seemingly clear path to this Super
Bowl and we are down 24 [ __ ] nothing
24 nothing we had down for [ __ ] scores
to win expansion team ok
so then what the Chiefs get the ball
back or some [ __ ] like that right and
then the [ __ ] Ravens go out there
ok maybe got a first down or whatever
it's fourth down kick the [ __ ] ball
away crowds a little bit into it just
kick the [ __ ] ball make him make him
earn the touchdown they call a fake
[ __ ] punt and once again Tony Romo
goes I'd like that call if they did
something something quicker they would
have had it somebody explain this to me
because we've already established that
I'm just this old guy all right you guys
have tweeted
enough times the picture Clint
Eastwood's sitting on his front porch
your [ __ ] hacks you guys all use the
same [ __ ] gift thinking you're
brilliant
alright please explain to me why do
teams go for it on fourth down in the
first [ __ ] half why would you do that
[ __ ] what you're up by [ __ ] three
touchdowns in a field goal why the [ __ ]
would you even consider that why the
[ __ ] would you call a fake punt on your
side of the 50
dude that stadium came alive and I don't
think they ever got the [ __ ] momentum
back you're up 24 [ __ ] points and you
can't even be you don't even have a lead
at halftime I don't know man that thing
that was such I guess who goes for the
kill shot in the first [ __ ] quarter
or the beginning of the second quarter
there's no kill shot there isn't you're
gonna play 60 minutes and I swear to god
with the [ __ ] prevent defense every
game comes down to the [ __ ] wire take
the whatever points you can get on every
[ __ ] Drive and you're on your side of
the 50 punt the [ __ ] ball away these
are not groundbreaking thoughts here on
football there's a reason why people
have always done that because it [ __ ]
works it made me like I said I didn't
have a dog in that fight but it made me
sick to my stomach
watching them [ __ ] that game up like
that okay here's the thing you don't you
just [ __ ] kick the field goal and you
don't go for it you punt the [ __ ]
ball I'm not saying Kansas City wouldn't
come back I mean it's a hell of a team
they have obviously but like you you I
just feel you it just changed the whole
game like did they wouldn't let's say
just the normal kind of comeback
happened it would have taken until the
end of the third [ __ ] quarter now
granted also as much [ __ ] as the coach
is going to take after Kansas City
scores alright to make it [ __ ] what
24/7 and what they did they
the ball off its it happened so goddamn
fast they kick it off and then they
fumbled the [ __ ] ball on the kickoff
for a touchdown I mean that's not the
coach's fault but Kansas City was so
favored so favored and they were down by
so many [ __ ] points they were like
you saw it in their faces
did you see what my homes look like when
he was sitting on the [ __ ] bench it
look like it was the end of the fourth
quarter and the game was over not saying
that he quit but he had a look on his
face then that's that's that's the look
you want on that guy's face Kansas City
was exactly who they thought they were
and they let him off the hook that game
was a [ __ ] travesty I mean I
shouldn't really do this because I bet
Kansas City fans like though what about
the fact that we scored like 41
unanswered points yeah I know it was
amazing it was amazing but like I mean
it's not like the Texans didn't help
here along with those oh my god just
considering that fourth down you know
it's like you had a vampire with a stake
three quarters of the way in and then
for some reason you stopped hitting the
hammer and started to pull it out right
is the things eyes were gonna close so
anyway one of the most amazing comebacks
I've ever seen but the fact that the
Texans helped him along I just I felt I
don't know that was the last time I saw
something like that was when the
Patriots came back against the [ __ ]
the Falcons but it was my team so I
could totally enjoy it but even then I
there was there's just a sickening
feeling you don't want to see anybody do
that man
that was a whew that kind of redefined
the the old [ __ ] show they don't hang on
a second somebody's at the door all
right I'm back I'm back anyway so so
what do we got next week we got the
Titans versus the Kansas City Chiefs all
right I'm a stand-up comedian what the
[ __ ] do I know all right here's my
prediction
a lot of people like somebody text me
said there's no way the Titans are
beating the [ __ ] Chiefs I don't know
as much as the Chiefs had an incredible
game they also led up 31 points and like
374 yards passing and the Titans got
that [ __ ] what's his name Henry Derek
Henry's that was name I don't know I
missed the [ __ ] I met you so much out
here traveling I don't know I just they
got a quarterback they got a running
back they got a good defense
I just think tanned they got Vrabel who
seems to be showing the world that he's
an unbelievable coach he also came up
under Belichick so I kind of got a route
for him I don't that's a weird one
because I want to I want to root for the
underdog here but also like Kansas
City's been waiting for so [ __ ] long
and I'm so old that the Titans are still
an expansion franchise even though
they're not they're an old AFL team they
used to be the Houston Oilers but as far
as like being a nash tip to people in
Ashfield right in do you really care
about NFL football come on you live in
Nashville right you're out there
listening to country music all my router
frames are come and open that right is
that what you're doing out there [ __ ]
with you I know you give a [ __ ] I think
it's going to be a close game and one of
the only question mark I think on the
Kansas City has been their defense and I
don't know I think their defensive backs
I don't know they're not saying they're
bad but I don't know how good they are
so we shall see what the [ __ ] do I know
right and it's looking like my [ __ ]
sneaky pete pic here is not gonna come
in why do you give a [ __ ] you know when
you make like a prediction why do I give
a [ __ ] you know you know why cuz virzi
picked the Packers to play the Patriots
in the there you go there you go look at
that [ __ ] Seahawks might come right
out and score a touchdown get themselves
back into this game he picked the
Packers in the end and the the Patriots
and I picked the Ravens
in Seattle so obviously both of our AFC
picks are out of the picture and so this
game here comes down to me verse virzi
and it's looking like he's gonna win
this one
unless Wilson can leave these guys in
right now
I was hoping Marshawn Lynch was gonna do
a little bit more especially when they
gave him all those extra pushes I was
loving that oh my god it's great piss
off Marshawn Lynch that's a smart
[ __ ] move that's like going for a
fake punt on your side of the 50 Jesus
Christ I swear to God I swear to guy
almost felt like Roger Goodell called
him called up that Coach and was was
like people are turning off the game
we're gonna lose a fortune do something
stupid let him back in the game I'm
telling you that's been my conspiracy
theory that the prevent defense was
actually designed to make sure every
game was never out of reach so people
wouldn't shut games off during the third
[ __ ] quarter well at least they would
do it as little as possible and
everybody would look like Elway in
Montana and Marino you know Roger
Staubach all those guys you know very
few quarterbacks back in the day could
do what the [ __ ] every quarterback seems
to be able to do now which is go 80
yards with under two minutes left in a
game and then get four shots at the
[ __ ] endzone so alright with that
congratulations to everybody who want
crazy games crazy games all right let me
read a little bit of advertising here so
I type in my [ __ ] password once again
I don't know what you guys like if this
if this stays this way Packers will have
to go into San Francisco you know one of
the fans had a sign that kind of pissed
me off said the Daiya the the Empire is
rising or something like that I was like
Empire I don't think the 49ers ever had
an empire they had a dynasty they didn't
have an empire ok the Yankees had a
[ __ ] Empire the Celtics had an empire
right
[ __ ] football man you went four or
five the Patriots don't have an empire
we had a [ __ ] sick run we had the
greatest [ __ ] run since they've been
counting Super Bowls but like as I
always maintain the New York Yankees of
football as are the Green Bay Packers if
they counted Super Bowls and NFL titles
which would be amazing if the Packers
win this one I believe would be their
fifth I want to say what it wait a
second wait a second one they two with
Bart Starr they won one with Brett Favre
and Aaron Rodgers has one right
yeah that's fourth so then they'd be in
the the upper echelon that Bob bill shut
the [ __ ] up and read some goddamn copy
all right here's some copy for you I
just literally heard that woman yawn
next to her she goes mm-hmm think I'm
boring her with my football talk you
know or maybe she just woke up from her
slumber so she can go holla at the
[ __ ] moon again all right
brave everybody brave is the web browser
you know some I should really go on the
other [ __ ] room filled she's hearing
every [ __ ] word of this and pretty
soon I've had that happen to me on
podcasts in the past you know I think
that happened to me in New Jersey one
time I had security come to the door
people are complaining that you're
screaming and yelling and I'm just like
I am who's in there with you nobody all
right here we go safe confines here at
the bedroom all right let's do a little
bit of reading here Oh brave everybody
everybody's brave right but are they
brave enough to call their company brave
now that's real that's real brave 'ti
brave is the web browser reimagined keep
your personal information private as you
surf the web here we go yeah because
there's somebody else advertising here
who's not exactly doing that I got to
rethink that [ __ ] contract all right
but if you can't figure out what the
[ __ ] they're doing hey we'll help you
buy [ __ ] and it cost you nothing what's
in it for you just ask those questions
people and you should be fine all right
people you are living in the
surveillance economy here's someone's
trying to stop that right now every time
you download
webpage you are not just downloading the
content parentheses texts and images you
are also downloading privacy invading
trackers wait until you realize how
pathetic people are advertisers and [ __ ]
that they need to do this
how much more [ __ ] do they need to sell
us it's like the whole [ __ ] ocean is
full of the crap nobody wants anymore
it's fetid I don't know somebody sits
there and figures this [ __ ] out and
[ __ ] watches what goddamn toothpaste
you want anyways wait until you hear
what information about you is shared
your digital profile can include your
inferred sexual orientation that's
hilarious
well he's mainly watched heterosexual
porn II went a little sideways here a
couple of times
political views religious beliefs or
even what types of medical issues you
might have that includes what you are
reading watching and listening to it
includes your location sometimes right
up to your exact GPS coordinates so if
you like looking I always say tooth be
looking at toothpaste then they'll just
pop up an ad right for toothpaste and
then a pharmacy right around the corner
is that what that doing it has to be a
program there's not enough people to
watch all the people in the world
anyways and it includes unique ID codes
that are specific to you as your social
security number said all of this data
can be tied to you continually over time
this allows companies you have never
heard of to maintain intimate profiles
about you and what makes you tick and on
everyone you know data collected about
you can be used to manipulate your
decisions but also countrywide decisions
like elections take Cambridge analytical
for example I don't know what that is
what if you're a contrarian though they
probably figure out that you're a
contrarian so then they show you the
candidate they don't want you to vote
for right anyway but there's a way to
protect yourself and remove the
surveillance economy start using brave
brave stops data grabbing trackers and
creepy ads from following you across the
web which allows you to browse up to
six times faster than with other
browsers oh that's cool so stop allowing
the surveillance economy to take
advantage of you it's time to turn off
the manipulation engine not to mention
it's your personal information so
shouldn't you get a cut of it I know
they're doing the work gathering it but
it's still you right can't they can't
kick you a little 10 percent switching
to brave is easy import your bookmarks
with one click and in less than 60
seconds you'll be enjoying a better
internet it's free and all your Chrome
extensions work in brave what do you
mean it's free why is it frog listen to
listeners of the podcast can switch to
brave for free today go to brave comm /
/ and download brave today that's brave
calm / / and switch today this is also
free so how are they making money oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy you want this car
it's free oh yeah I don't have to be
just in business to not make money Oh
max if you're one of thousands that have
purchased Oh max Health's cryofreeze CBD
the pain relief roll-on that's been
coming to the rescue for so many of my
listeners according to this copy this is
okay to help instantly relieve joint
pain then you don't want to miss this
this is a brand-new product that and
it's the first time people talked about
this on this podcast Oh max has given
gives you an exclusive on the launch of
their new cryofreeze CBD sport recovery
cream cryofreeze CBD BBD CBD poison
sport recovery cream provides instant
cooling and relief relief and moisture
so it can be used daily to refresh and
revitalize tired and achy achy joints
and muscles so why do you need this in
addition to the rule the pain relief
roll-on provides
are going to release forever for every
painful area I use that [ __ ] on my
frozen shoulder it's been helping me out
man and it makes it feel wintery green
fresh for when my wife puts her head on
my frozen chew please don't move my arm
sweetie the sport recovery cream is an
ultra rich moisturizing cream with the
same icy cold relief as the roll-on but
it can be used all over your body
including your legs feet back shoulders
wrists and hands that's not all your
body I thought they're gonna keep going
the powerhouse recovery cream includes
broad-spectrum CB d BB D with 0% THC so
there's absolutely no high okay
plus 10 natural healing botanicals
including magnesium which is great for
muscle cramps and arnica for circulation
and bruising it features can a
microsphere technology which is a new
delivery system for CBD that only Oh max
has which helps deliver fast and more
powerful results so if you have sore
muscles backache stiff joints or just
feel like you need to revitalize your
body then you cannot miss try trying the
cryofreeze CBD sport recovery cream I'm
gonna need this [ __ ] for my tongue if
this goddamn copy gets any longer Oh max
is offering my listeners here we go here
we go here's the money shot 20% off
there Oh max cryo free support recovery
cream plus shipping is free this
discount also applies towards any
products site-wide through the end of
this month just go - Oh max calm today
that's all mah alth calm and enter code
Barbie you are that's all max health
calm and enter code bird to get 20% off
Oh max cryofreeze sports recovery cream
and site-wide alright lastly but not
leastly and then i'm gonna announce my
new date man he looks okay here's my
hilux ass alright
Oh No why are they trying to write [ __ ]
for me okay this is their copy hi I'm
Bill burr I'm a really I'm really a I'm
a really unique guy I am NOT I shop at
the gap about his [ __ ] mainstream as
it gets that's why you like my podcast
or don't like it I don't get I don't
care but I'm truly one-of-a-kind why are
they making me talk about my I sound
like a [ __ ] wide receiver right now
one in a bigger contract which is why I
sleep on a mattress designed
specifically for me and you can too next
please mention all the talking points
below hallux helix built a sleek quiz
that takes two minutes to complete and
they use the answers to match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress it shouldn't be for the
perfect mattress for you - the perfect
mattress all for you all right if you
like mattress if you like a mattress
that's really soft or firm you sleep on
your side or on your back or your on
your stomach or you sleep really hot
gross with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's unique
taste hey you know [ __ ] funny it is
if you're a hot sleeper like what's
going on with you that you're just lean
usually you lay in the couch you're not
moving you know your body temperature
tends to I know you get a little chill
you reach up for an Afghan even in the
middle of July the fact that you're
laying there
roasting spontaneously combusting just
go to helix sleep calm / / take that two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life like me like me
I guess I don't they got to stop doing
this [ __ ] I just want to read what the
[ __ ] it is stop having it oh gee I
[ __ ] jerked off on this hellix sleep
was even awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2019 by GQ &
Wired magazine they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free grows they'll
even pick it up if you don't like it an
even grosser
that's nice one maybe like I didn't like
it alright just stick it out back then
no charge
no we're gonna go down and get it
they're gonna go down and get it yeah
okay
right now helix is offering up to $200
off the mattress orders for our
listeners get up to $200 off helix sleep
comm / / alright new dates they go down
and get it everybody just like when you
[ __ ] turn in your old cellphone they
keep it alright
new dates alright March 27th I'm gonna
be in Reno Nevada at the Grand Sierra
Resort and Casino
April 9th I'm gonna be in Atlanta
Georgia at the coca-cola Roxy April 14th
I'm gonna be in Nashville Tennessee at
the Ryman Auditorium for Nashville the
Nashville Comedy Festival and May 1st
I'm gonna be at the Indianapolis Indy in
Indianapolis Indiana at the Murat
theater all right to get you goddamn
tickets if you can alright okay what do
we got here what do we got here how much
time alight dunya it's almost time to
start reading the questions but you know
what else is time for it's time for old
freckles to check in on the game to see
what's happening all right
can the Seattle Seahawks I didn't like
that clown he went down man I didn't
know that he was [ __ ] her - that is
that's a major factor I'll tell you
tales of the tape for someone like me
who's told jokes for almost 30 years and
hasn't played organized football in
[ __ ] 40 I'm gonna give you my [ __ ]
opinions here I don't have any opinions
I picked the Seattle Seahawks and I want
them to win cuz I don't want to listen
to verse you tell me that once again he
was right at least his pick went further
than mine come on
all right we got a chick on a couch Fox
it's on Fox what do we got here oh god I
got Green Bay Packers smiling and
dancing on the sidelines all right come
on come on give me a game give me oh the
Packers are kicking off its twenty eight
to ten all right so they're down by 18
so you know what that means if they get
it down to the one-yard line and it's
fourth and one then they should
automatically just just go for it right
is that how you do it all right
Packers jumping around I gotta tell you
this generation of football players they
are so amazed every time they make a
[ __ ] tackle jumping up and down fist
pumping I mean there's some celebrations
out here that there are more than what I
would do if I won the [ __ ] lottery oh
Jesus Christ
why the [ __ ] would I bet against Aaron
Rodgers what kind of what kind of why
the [ __ ] would I ever do that he sees
you see the bigger the game the better
the guy plays what the [ __ ] was I
thinking did I did I give Pete Carroll
too much credit I'll tell you right now
Pete Carroll should have chewed to
pieces of gum for this [ __ ] game come
on Russell make a game out of it he
throws the ball and it's [ __ ] short
all right no bears in Memphis all right
hey Billy bear hunter hey bear bear
hunter bill I should say I swear to God
I have some sort of low-level [ __ ]
dyslexia I don't know what it is what
how could I read hey bear hunter bill is
hey Billy bear hunter is there a
dyslexia where you just try to guess
what the sentence says rather than
reading it hey how about those Boston
Bruins I [ __ ] watched all three games
this week the Predators the [ __ ]
Winnipeg Jets how fun are they to watch
and they beat the Islanders last night
that [ __ ] Winnipeg Jets game was one
of the best hockey games I've seen this
this season and I'm not saying that
because the Bruins want pasta NOK had
[ __ ] he scored goals 33 34 and 35 and
had a hat-trick against the Winnipeg
Jets Bergeron had the game-winner in
overtime against the Islanders and John
Moore got his second point of the year
was [ __ ] great fun week to be a Bruins
fan by the way shoutout to that [ __ ]
guy in the Avalanche I forget the guys
name I got to post this video man
as far as like as far as like sticking
up for your teammate this is just like
this is that my favorite one before this
one was Adam McQuaid when he fought Rafi
Torres when he elbowed Andrew Ference
look up Adam McQuaid vs. Rafi Torres and
that's basically how it's done and if
you would like a newer version I forget
the guys name I should know his name but
I don't have time to [ __ ] look it up
the guy in the car Colorado Avalanche
fight net dude on the Rangers the guy
had a questionable hit most of the
shoulder was to the chest area but he
came I think he caught his chin a little
bit and the guy went down and this guy
went over and just beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of this guy just throwing haymakers
and was connecting it was it was
borderline heroic what this man did I
just wish there was more of that in the
the NHL and be honest with you that
that's what needed to be done
to the st. Louis Blues last year and
nobody had the guy to do it we all
showed up with these finesse teams and
that bla mask team with one [ __ ] line
won the Cup I don't think I'll ever get
over it
what should make people in st. Louis
enjoy the fact that it's still bothering
me if we just did that once though their
balls would have pulled up into their
body and they would have played like the
[ __ ] mediocre team that they were all
right another first down for Seattle
that's [ __ ] bill [ __ ] you they beat
you fair and square all right they did
all right hey bear hunter bill love the
comedy and the podcast I was at your
stand-up show Monday night and thought
it was terrific just wanted to give you
a heads up though that we don't have
bears in Memphis I realized that dude
that was the joke the Grizzlies is a
dumb team name for the town but whatever
no it was the Vancouver Grizzlies Jesus
Christ you don't even know your your own
history here
there was the Vancouver Grizzlies were a
NBA franchise there for I don't know
eight nine seasons or something I don't
know how long they were up there I just
remember they had really ugly uniforms
and they had this big white dude in big
country that came from either Oklahoma
State University Oklahoma
and it's like the Utah Jazz it made
sense when it was the New Orleans jazz
and Utah for some reason I don't know
why they didn't change it maybe because
they're Mormons and they're just super
friendly and it's like well we don't
want New Orleans to feel like they had a
bad name for their team so we'll just
keep it that's why you're called the
grizzly anyways he says the the grizzly
is a dumb name for a team team name for
the town but whatever that being said I
still think the average Memphian knows
that bears in fact don't give a [ __ ] I
attached a map of where you can find
bears in North America quick question
for you what is your best advice for
someone from the Yankee north to go
hunting and have you ever been hunting
did you get the chance to see the
Grizzlies play yet yes I have are any
NBA action at all this year yeah I saw
them in the New Orleans pelicans and
I've seen a home game of every team in
the NBA now thanks for coming to Memphis
all the best and go [ __ ] yourself have I
ever been hunting
I went both fish hunting in New Orleans
a long time ago with this actor that was
really into hunting and he took me and
we got in this [ __ ] truck drove out
to the Bayou stopped at a gas station
bought a fishing license the next thing
you know it's nighttime in the middle of
[ __ ] August and I'm out on the Bayou
with this guy and these real-deal Cajun
guys who had flashlights and they were
pointing at the fish with shallow water
and then we just pointed the fish they'd
see a fish they just go right that right
there right now right now I feel like I
just told this story in the podcast so I
did do that and I liked it until I
realized we weren't gonna be eating the
fish and then I stopped I was like I
don't want to be just out here killing
[ __ ] that'd be killing the [ __ ] but I
have never gone out and hunted for
anything but I could do it if I had to
if I was [ __ ] starving I could shoot
a [ __ ] deer right in the head I do it
right in front of its little [ __ ] kid
you know I'd shoot the kid too though
you know I'd take out the whole family's
a [ __ ] deer serial killer I don't
know how I don't know the rules of it
I don't know but you know that the way
they treat chickens and cows and pigs
and all that type of [ __ ] is bad as much
[ __ ] is people give hunters if they got
to eat all the meat and the fact that
the thing actually lived a life out
there where it was free I don't think
it's that bad right I do I do though I
don't understand killing bears though
what the reason for that is or if there
is like a population problem but it is
kind of funny as human beings to say
that there is a population problem when
there's no for whatever reason
population problem with us I always I
always use that antidote that's like the
[ __ ] you know the person who can see
cheating on the other team but doesn't
see it on on their own team when it's
literally could be literally the exact
same infraction and you know it just
doesn't make any it just doesn't
register alright so that's it all I know
is bears are [ __ ] terrifying I saw
this there's a YouTube video of this
[ __ ] idiot he walks up to like a
black bear and I guess black bears are
kind of like afraid of human beings
they're not as big but it's still a
goddamn bear and Russell Wilson is
literally taking upon himself right now
to just [ __ ] get this team to come
down the field one minute 121 to go in
the third quarter case you're trying to
sync up his podcast so he's telling this
bear to get the [ __ ] out of there right
and the bear is actually complying and
it's walking away but because this
douche is videoing himself I think he
wants to seem like a badass and for
whatever reason he walks up behind the
bear you can't see it but evidently he
kicked the bear and the bear paw turns
around pauses for a second before like
it's like it's debating like am I am I
gonna [ __ ] just walk away from this
and have to carry the fact that I let
touchdown Seattle oh oh
[Music]
sneaking back in it sneak it back in it
now do you go for to here
to get yourself within 10 I love this
like you don't have any faith in your
[ __ ] offense just take whatever
[ __ ] points you can get here you
watch this is they're gonna go for
[ __ ] two points here and everybody's
gonna be like I agree with this I agree
with this because you know why take
white white [ __ ] can be 11 points down
you know when you can actually be twelve
points down oh they're gonna kick it
alright thank God okay great fantastic
okay so this [ __ ] bear turns around
and then as somebody mentions in the
comment it starts growling it sounded
like a [ __ ] dirt bike and then this
guy's all this guy's bright now he's
backing up and this [ __ ] thing to the
you know every one of that pause could
be Freddy Krueger's [ __ ] glove comes
running at this guy and the phone goes
flying out of his hands you heared the
struggle and when the guy gets up he's
got the audacity to be like that [ __ ]
thing bit my hand
it's like bit your hand you're lucky it
didn't [ __ ] eat you from the inside
out was just screaming in agony what
kind of a [ __ ] jerk off first of all
to be in the [ __ ] woods the bear has
more right to be there than you do
considering a bear can't go to the mall
right you shouldn't be able to go out in
the goddamn [ __ ] woods am i nuts I
mean that's that you're now playing an
away game you're in his [ __ ] stadium
and you're telling that thing to get the
[ __ ] out of there and you're booting it
in the ass like it showed up uninvited
to your Super Bowl party then you have
the decency to bring a [ __ ] six-pack
this [ __ ] idiot goes up and he kicks
him right in his furry ass and I gotta
tell you something I thought that the
bear showed a lot of restraint like I
say at Thomas when he didn't went into
the crowd showed a lot of restraint
should have punched that dude right in
his [ __ ] mouth and then that good
could have used his [ __ ] uh Slurpee
whatever the hell he wanted to win
you know the ice of that to make his lip
go back down anyway I'll post that video
anger franchise dear Billy balderdash on
the last Monday morning podcast one 620
that was not the last one so
oh wait was it no maybe it was you're
right it was some reason I throws later
in the month you talked about how you
made no progress in the resolving your
anger issue based on your blow-up at the
reasonably angering Apple Store I don't
pretend to be someone who has dealt with
anger issues to your extent but my
brother very much has parentheses though
he's more the bottling up type that's
amazing that you guys are in the same
family and one person as a Temperance
somebody else doesn't and anyways person
goes on to say and do to the years of
observing and trying to help him get
through his issues
I feel qualified to tell you that you
shouldn't base your progress off of one
incident instead look at the bigger
picture exclamation point well I am
looking at the bigger picture sir that
was just the story I told you the bigger
picture is too sad to look at anyways
one you don't blow up nearly as often as
you used to as far as I can tell all
right
you acknowledge your behavior almost
immediately being self-aware like that
is a bigger step then most give credit
for okay I like this as purses make me
feel better
Apple does suck and your theory about
them making their products near obsolete
within 18 months is spot-on number four
the way you talk about everyday life on
the podcast have become more and more
positive every year if you don't see
slash here and go listen to one of your
own through your own throwback Thursday
episode and listen to how far you've
come just in the last eight years oh
look at that I'm a better me all right
28 17 Seattle's down by 11
it's [ __ ] the end of the third
quarter here number 97 on the Packers is
either explaining how somebody [ __ ] up
his dinner last night or what they need
to be doing in the fourth quarter and
then he put too much [ __ ] salt in it
all right if I were to compare your prog
your progression with anger issues to
that of an NFL franchise I like this
this guy
audience I would call you the Kansas
City Chiefs what
I haven't [ __ ] been I had a good day
in 50 years sure you haven't won the
Super Bowl during this timeframe but
you've been putting a great product on
the field and no one is doubting that
you are at the very least a Super Bowl
contender
thanks for putting out great content
every week and you really helped us all
plow through the work week well isn't
that one of the most positive whatever
emails I've ever gotten yeah I need I
got a well is this thing sir before it
was bad enough that my wife had to deal
with it and now I have it I have a
little beautiful kid so I have to work
on that but like I said what I like is
Mike my daughter is not afraid of me at
all which is a big change from the way I
grew up where kids were afraid of their
parents she believed me she does what I
say although I do have to say it two or
three times because I joke with her so
much that she kind of has to look at me
like is this one of these things where
you say don't do it and then I do it and
then you pretend to chase me around and
we have a great time
are you actually serious so I am a
little bit there but like when I do flip
out as I'm flipping out she just goes
daddy dad dad stop stop you know you
have to be nice to people Mike you're
right buddy you're right you're right
what am i doing this makes no sense give
me a hug and then we go play something
all right
Jillian Michaels I remember from the
Biggest Loser right
bill did you hear what Jillian Michaels
said about Liz oh to be inappropriate I
don't know who Liz oh is is that a
singer was that the person who was the
musical guest when Eddie Murphy hosted
SNL
I don't know anyways I'm a 42 year old
woman and I'm I was overweight in my in
my early 30s my attitude towards being
overweight was certainly informed by my
own apathy and laziness before my health
dependent on losing 125 pounds I don't
appreciate people making crude fat jokes
but also don't mind
rhetoric rhetoric implying weight loss
is more healthy than not much love from
Chicago
alright so was it something I said
because I always make fun of the fatties
all right let's see what Jillian
Michaels said I'm looking you brought
that up and now I got a [ __ ] Google
here Jillian Michaels Liz oh well
Jillian Michaels was also in the public
eye and then she came out of the public
eye so maybe she wants to try to get
back into it by doing the Madonna thing
Liz Oh responds to Jillian Michaels body
shaming comments Bob Harper was asked
about Jillian oh so she bought E okay
here we go here we go oh boy oh boy what
did she say is it gonna be anything
worse than I've ever said all right
Jillian Michaels comments on Liz's
weight for the third time this week
after backlash she's doubling down
Triplett down she won't go back to the
room it's a cold deck of cards and she
keeps playing all right Jillian Michaels
just reiterated her feelings about Liz
OHS wait for the third time Jillian said
there's nothing beautiful about clogged
arteries in her latest statement yeah
she's right I mean at this point she's
going beyond political correctness and
she's trying to save somebody's life
that's probably how she's looking at it
but I'm sure that Liz Oh knows this the
former Biggest Loser trainer has faced
significant backlash for her comments
earlier this week celebrity trainer
that's such a funny job named celebrity
trainer I only try to get famous people
in shape if you're a regular person
driving a truck you can die of a heart
attack [ __ ] all right unless you
got the money to pay me
all right Jillian Michaels came under
fire for her comments fat shaming singer
Liz oh all right here we go all right
here we go what did she say personal
trainer blah blah blah blah you died had
done it
Oh am I supposed to listen to this
alright
Jillian first mentioned her thoughts on
Liz oh during an
interview yesterday with BuzzFeed am ii
DM series while talking about
celebrities who promote self-acceptance
she brought up liz oh and how she
doesn't think it's right to glorify
obesity why are we celebrating her body
ooh Jesus she went she both feet she
stuck both her [ __ ] cross-trainers
right into that [ __ ] pool Wow
why Chile replied why does it matter why
does it matter that's what I'm saying
like why aren't we celebrating her music
cuz it's gonna be awesome because it
isn't gonna be awesome if she gets
diabetes I'm just being honest I love
her music my kid loves her music but
there's never a moment when I'm like I'm
so glad she's overweight overweight why
do I even care why is it my job to care
about her weight and there was nothing
after that when he was as I've stated
repeatedly we are all beautiful worthy
equally deserving I also feel strongly
that we love ourselves enough to
acknowledge that there are serious
health consequences when it comes with
obesity heart disease diabetes cancers
to name only a few she wrote I would
never wish these for anyone and I would
hope we prioritize our health because we
love ourselves in our bodies all right
well you know she kind of you know
that's one of those kitchen-table
statements that you make publicly and
then it becomes like this big [ __ ]
thing and in defense of her people also
went really far the other way to start
saying that people who were one ticking
time bombs were brave for being that way
there's got to be like a happy medium
between what she said and then just you
know building statues for people like
that but whatever at the end of the day
it's their body it's their business you
know if they want to have that bacon
[ __ ] double cheeseburger then I would
love to have every goddamn night you
know and and you know in one way they
are living a dream you know his is the
positive side of dying of obesity is you
ate whatever the [ __ ] you want it to
whenever you wanted to you said [ __ ] it
you know and in the end if there is some
place
you go after this alright which lasts
for infinity what is the big [ __ ]
deal that you only got 40 years and
someone else got 80 years if you ate all
the [ __ ] bacon double cheeseburgers
and mint chocolate chip ice cream that
you want it you know there there's
different philosophies when it comes to
life so if somebody's saying like listen
I know I'm a fat [ __ ] but uh you know I
eat whatever I everything I eat is ala
mode and I'm having a [ __ ] great time
doing it you know if they want to do
that you know but I think if you're
gonna do that you should purchase like
some sort
you should widen your front door so
people don't have to cut you out you
know and wheel you down the street you
know if you make that decision you I
think they should have like a [ __ ]
like a greased up slide or something so
they can get you into the truck after
you pass away because that that would be
one thing like you know I have such a
need to be like even after I'm dead I'm
like well I don't want my body to be a
burden I don't want to blow out
somebody's [ __ ] back as they try to
pick me up off my [ __ ] air mattress
alright okay so she could ask me did you
find what Jillian Michaels said about
Liz oh to be inappropriate um listen I
that's I wouldn't know but I must have
at this point I've made fun of so many
fat people
I guess cuz I'm a [ __ ] jackass
comedian I'm not a personal trainer
Seattle Seattle is coming back to life
the chest pumping I don't know man I I
wouldn't I I always do it joking around
I mean I'm serious and I want you to
lose the weight and everything but I
would never want to single one person
out specifically and hurt their feelings
like that as much as I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like I I don't like like I've
told some jokes like three or four times
in my life I'd made somebody cry in the
audience and I always felt bad
afterwards you know and it's just like
that's not what I want to do there was
one time I did it in some was just being
the overly sensitive white chick and
then I was just like I'll grow the [ __ ]
up but then there's other times I just
touched on subjects that people had you
know we had a personal connection to and
like you know I didn't I I'm always
going down there I'm always going for
the laughs and I have oak so I've done a
lot of body shaving but I feel like I've
done it in a positive way with its which
is what I think she's trying to do here
to motivate but you know there's this
you know it's a it's it's he walking a
little bit of a tightrope when you do
that but I be honest with you I've had a
ton of form of fat people come up to me
saying I listen to your podcast and I
got a laugh out of it like I swear to
God I body shame myself like today I've
been in down south so you know what it
is the notch on the belt is gonna move
over in the wrong direction so today
when I put the belt on it wasn't you
know and I could have gone for the
comfort and I didn't I said no you're
gonna [ __ ] feel the pain of your
stupid decisions and I [ __ ] had it
tight and was digging into my [ __ ]
waist you know what I went out and I got
a salad so you know and when I stand in
the mirror and I don't have a shirt and
I got a look at you you [ __ ] pills
very [ __ ] freckled Doughboy i trashed
the [ __ ] out of myself and that works
for me so I guess you gotta understand
that doesn't work for everybody
but I don't know I think probably enough
people are saying mean [ __ ] to where I
don't think you need the property pile
on which I don't think she was doing it
just it just didn't come out right
like I think everybody should get over
it considering we're thinking about
starting a fourth war while we're still
fighting three others it's probably
bigger things to talk about I guess I
don't know probably could pick my words
a little careful what I mean bigger huh
you mean fatter is that the [ __ ] is that
alright broke alright you were you were
right deal dear Billy Brown okay Brown
University did a study about the cost of
war and mapped out the debt the u.s. has
accrued since 9/11 a couple big
takeaways the amount of interest the
u.s. pays back on the annual basis went
from 232 billion to
532 billion in 20 years Jesus Christ and
knowing how interest works it's not just
2.5 times the debt two and a half times
the debt that's two and a half times the
interest which compounds to trillions on
a payment schedule if there is one if no
more debt is accrued the US would have
its war debt paid off by 2050 with an
estimate of six point one trillion spent
in interest the debt isn't just owed to
banks thirty-four percent is owned to
private investors private investors are
making money off of this [ __ ] either the
world is just an evil place who loans
money to [ __ ] killing regular people
and babies it's just [ __ ] beyond me I
swear I don't understand how war is
still legal in 20 is advanced as we are
as human beings that you can still
involve this hey we're gonna kill more
of your people then you can kill of ours
and then you're gonna give up is just
that there's got to be another [ __ ]
way to resolve this [ __ ] I maintain
that you need to give the sun to oil
companies and banks and let them own
that [ __ ] so cuz they're always going to
own the energy and they're always going
to own us right so give them the clean
one as long as they're making the same
amount of [ __ ] money you know I guess
you know we can get out of our interest
in all of these [ __ ] people's natural
resources around the [ __ ] world
corporations in first world countries
I'm not just picking on us just all
around the world their idea that that
the natural resources around the world
are theirs is incredibly short-sighted
and it's leading to a great just
craziness which is why I watch football
in sports I can't even read the rest of
this [ __ ] but if I'll have the okay 34
percent is owned to private banks 20
sent to foreign and international
investors investors I invest in war only
11% of it is owned to the Federal
Reserve this exposes the fact that just
controlling the money system isn't
enough there's much more that's
interesting point there's much more
money to be made lending during wartime
next time someone makes fun of you for
bringing the cost of these perpetual
Wars sanctioned by both Democrat and
Republican administrators yes Sarah of
course we know that you saw when Trump
tried to pull the troops out of Syria
all of a sudden all those liberal
lefties were right there with the people
on the right well well well what are we
doing it's not bite the hand that feeds
let them know that the reason they're
not angry about it too is because it's a
very complicated issue and if they were
educated on it they'd be disturbed as
well well I'm not educated on it I was
just [ __ ] you know what I'll retweet
this [ __ ] link here it's it says
Watson Brown cost of war 2020 I think if
you google that you can find it and read
it instead of doing whatever [ __ ] job
you're supposed to be doing in the
cubicle there all right need advice
boyfriend's boyfriend [ __ ] up his
first impression with what your parents
but with you if it's with you then just
you know move on alright dear Billy
drummer boy I'm a relatively new
listener of the podcast but I absolutely
love it and your specials are actually a
topic with which I hit it off with my
boyfriend who isn't that great going to
binge listen to this whole to this while
studying and cleaning the dorm alright
I'm a 23 year old black girl in college
in blank blank blank blank I'm not gonna
say where you live I found my boyfriend
at you at the University we've been
together for five months and I fell for
him because of his jokes although you
don't see it immediately he had a very
sheltered upbringing in a rich white
neighborhood gated community Wow
it didn't really have much interaction
with black people I didn't really care
as he was funny and caring and his lack
of social sensitivity was quite
refreshing
looking back these should have been red
flags but I digress it depends on what
sort of social sensitivity
he doesn't have okay alright so I'm
trying to think what that means was it
refreshing to you that it was just a
white person being totally unfiltered
and honest so at least you knew where he
stood or was this the tip of the iceberg
boy for some reason I think he's gonna
buy you a Trump hat by the end of this
[Music]
anyway so the problem came when I
introduced him to my parents he started
off by trying to claim he liked Bill
Cosby and Dave Chapelle oh boy
look at these black people I like being
and she writes parentheses big lie and
was desperately desperately trying to
find a topic for my dad oh man oh god
how awkward was that that should be in a
comedy I offered that he should talk
about the 49ers my father is a fan I
don't know much please don't hate me
bill I'm not my boyfriend then loudly
proclaim that the 49ers suck and yada
yada
I give him a what the [ __ ] are you doing
look while my father gives him a small
smile on while his eyes are full of ice
and given me the side I already judging
my taste in men oh Jesus to finish the
evening off at dinner he tried to
impress me with some jokes and begin
because of that my parents that somehow
that's the end of the sentence to finish
the evening off at dinner he tried to
impress me with some jokes and because
of that my parents I think you edited
something here
he started joking and it was working
until he started to rant about the
neighborhood we live in the hippies the
dirtiness Berkeley being Berkeley my
parents are partial to the neighborhood
and their faces went to stone during
this whole time I was trying to stop him
with new topics
looks and even and under the table kick
at the end he just put through all of it
oh my god this is hilarious after dinner
my father stood up and calmly said to my
boyfriend that he should go back home
and that he wasn't welcome to stay the
night oh okay that's a wrap
dad then turned to me and just said that
I should be I he said he said I
shouldn't be with such an idiot which
after that horrific dinner I couldn't
even rebuke did he say that in front of
your boyfriend Wow
first down Seattle Seattle's driving
sneaky pete they might pull it off when
one of the Packers is down on the field
with 10:30 to go oh Jesus Christ I'm
telling you I thought I thought we'll
see we'll see that's a long long a lot
of time left anyways after that my dad
stood up okay he said he said it calmly
- Wow
okay it's now been two weeks and I'm
trying to get my parents to give him a
second chance
why relationships are so difficult you
don't don't don't do this anyways but I
obviously realized that it's also my
fault for not giving him the prep work
he obviously needed know you what do you
got a what for him to pretend to be
somebody else but I just didn't expect
it to go so bad so fast do I continue to
give them more time or should I dump him
and find someone with better social
skills I just don't know if it's worth
my time and efforts to fix this mess
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself it doesn't
listen okay this is something you need
to learn as soon as [ __ ] possible
okay you're not gonna change somebody
the fact that you hadn't you had to make
that much effort when you find the
person that you're supposed to be with
when you're hanging out together it's
effortless it fits together like a
[ __ ] puzzle if you bring somebody
home okay it'd be one thing if when you
guys were hanging out it was effortless
- blah blah blah blah blah blah you
already you're already said that you
know you kind of what saying that when
you were with him that he was funny and
not caring lack of social sensitivity
that they should have been some like
[ __ ] red flags maybe you're just
talking about your parents but no no no
relationships are hard enough you don't
need this extra [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
and one of the things that's going to be
a
really a [ __ ] weight around your neck
is if your parents just don't like who
the [ __ ] you're with your parents are
gonna be in your life for the rest of
their life okay
you don't need this [ __ ] this guy's
a [ __ ] idiot
and I don't I don't know what okay
whatever you're Berkeley you're trying
to find yourself you [ __ ] date and
all over the map by all means have a
great time figure out what the [ __ ]
but like you should be going home with
somebody thinking like I you know this
is the person I love this person and
like Marshawn Lynch touchdown Marshawn
Lynch touchdown here we go look at Pete
Carroll did he just give somebody the
finger did he say two points did he say
one I don't know what the [ __ ] just
happened there anyway um yeah I would
dump his ass I dumped his ass what do
you throw well the guy grew up in a
[ __ ] gated community I mean I'm Jesus
Christ all right I mean if you're into
that type of thing I guess if you find
that [ __ ] charming but like the first
look at pique yeah baby buggy yeah chew
his [ __ ] gum he's raising the roof
yeah yeah the five [ __ ] Pete Carril
I'm telling you oh my god
oh they're going for two here there's
ten minutes left
I don't understand this I don't
understand this and if they don't get it
to the crowd as something to cheer about
and he gets [ __ ] sacked great now
rather than the crowd being like oh [ __ ]
they're coming back they get a positive
out of this this is so [ __ ] what do I
know
look at little Pete Carroll's face what
a [ __ ] did I do that you know why cuz
you're [ __ ] Pete Carroll this is
[ __ ] Christ just kick the [ __ ] ball
and take the goddamn points can somebody
go back and listen to John Madden take
the points there's 10 minutes left what
do you think you're never gonna get down
there again so you gonna have to kick a
[ __ ] field goal you're gonna have at
least two to three more possessions
so stuck there wrong there [ __ ]
high-fiving each other right now and the
pack is lying on this sideline you just
scored a touchdown you had your foot on
their [ __ ] neck and then you gave my
slice of birthday cake and you helped
them up off the [ __ ] turf I don't
understand it
whatever I'm old yeah I would break up
with them I break up with them I mean I
don't know what your [ __ ] Malaysian I
mean I have to know you know listen I'm
a [ __ ] idiot and I say a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] but my wife when I met her
parents I'd she was not kicking me under
the table you know I went over there and
I was just I was being cool I was in
somebody's house I was being a [ __ ]
gentleman that's how you meet somebody's
parents you don't go over there and
[ __ ] put on your ass hat and start
running your [ __ ] hat and you're
kicking him under the table and he's
still not listening okay
this decision is yours do you want to
put that level of effort in if you got
to go interracial it's already gonna be
more [ __ ] effort just people looking
at you when you're walking down the
street I'm letting you know that from
obviously the [ __ ] experience after a
while you don't give a [ __ ] right but
I'm okay all right that's it all right
that's the podcast does sneaky pete
[ __ ] pull it off I think he might I
think he might all right
that's the podcast all right go [ __ ]
yourselves although maybe he doesn't
because they just they didn't they
didn't kick that [ __ ] extra point
there and look at look at the Packers
are all excited what are we gonna do
here all right he's hiking the ball
Aaron Rodgers the pummel he knocked the
ball down Jesus Christ what do I know
I don't know [ __ ] all right go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday let's go Tigers
can't say that they're both Tigers let's
go LSU where Bay Bay but the pepper Bay